foreign
in this video we will see the comparison
of react versus bluejs but before we
begin if you haven't subscribed to our
Channel already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and press the Bell icon
so you will never miss any update from
Simply love so without further Ado let's
begin and see what you need for you
first we'll see the introduction to view
and react.js after that we will see what
is react yes moving ahead we'll see the
features of react.js after that we will
see what is vue.js after that we will
see features of UJS and then we will see
why react is better than view JS and
after that we will see why view is
better than react.js we'll see the view
approach and react approaches after that
we will see the website that are using
View and react.js and when to choose
react or view JS so let's begin
View and react.js rs are capable
Flawless and satisfying particular
commercial categories
both JS Frameworks use properties
virtual Dom component based architecture
and chrome Dev tools for debugging now
let's move on to see what is react.js
react is a JavaScript library that is
used to build mobile and web
applications fast and Interactive it is
an open source reusable component based
front-end library for JavaScript react
is a combination of HTML and JavaScript
it provides a re-burst on an optimized
way to build modern applications
now let's move on to the features of
react.js the first one is js6 jsx is a
syntax extension to JavaScript with
react it is used to describe how the UI
should look like a jsx comes with all
the features of JavaScript
now let's move on to the second one
which is virtual document object model
which is Dom this defines how documents
are accessed and manipulated on the web
pages
the third one is performance there are
several ways to speed up the react
application by using virtual Dom because
it reduces the re-render time
the next one is one bit data binding
information Flows In One Way in react
react receives information through
arguments and passes it by returning
values the next one is extensions react
goes beyond simple UI and have many
extensions for complete application
support
the last and the final one is debugging
Facebook created a small browser
extension to make react debugging easier
and faster
now let's move on to see what is vue.js
of JavaScript framework called view is
used to create user interfaces it
provides a declarative and component
based programming approach that enables
you to quickly create your interface
regardless of how simple or difficult
they can be it works on top of
industrial standard HTTP CSS and
JavaScript HTML apps can be functions
thanks to vue.js directives built-in and
user defined directives are available in
UJS now let's move on to see features of
UJS
the first one is virtual Dom a virtual
representation of the Dom is called the
virtual Dom a JavaScript object
identically to the real Dom is
constructed using virtual Dom every time
a modification to the Dom is required a
new JavaScript object is formed and the
modification are made later the final
changes are updated in the actual Dom
after comparing the two JavaScript
objects
the second one is
data binding in view JS data binding
comes with a binding directives called V
bind the data binding functionalities
Assets in manipulating or assigning
values to the HTML attributes changing
the style and assigning classes
the next one is components components
are independent elements with their own
data Logics and Views one of the view JS
key features components enable the
creation of unique element that can be
reused throughout the HTML the next one
is event handling to listen to the
events in view.js the Dom events have
the property called Von which helps them
to listen to the events
the next one is transition or animation
when HTML elements are added changed or
removed from the Dom view JS offers a
variety of Technologies to apply the
transition
for the transition effect an element
must be wrapped in the built-in
transition components of vue.js the
interface can be more interactive and
third-party animation libraries are
simple to add the next one is Computing
properties one of the view JS key
characteristics is its Computing
properties paying attention to the UI
elements changes and makes appropriate
calculations in beneficial
no further coding is required for this
moving ahead we'll see what is templates
it provides HTML based templates that
connect the data from the vue.js
instance to the Dom
the templates are converted into the
simulated Dom render functions and the
template for render functions can be
used by web developers who can then swap
them out of the template from the render
function
moving ahead what is directives the
built-in directives in view JS can be
used to carry out various front-end
tasks including veif VLS we show V on
view build view model and viewbind and
the last feature of UJS is routing view
router is used to navigate between Pages
regardless of how the URL route was
updated view offers an interface to
adjust what is displaying on the page
now let's move on and see why is react
better than vue.js
react also have the advantages of
providing more API choices than virtual
Dom react.js gives developer more
options when creating bigger or more
complicated programs testing is simpler
in react among this supporting web
creation this service provides super
technological assistance with more
resources and information available
now let's see why vue.js is better than
react.js vue.js makes it easier and
faster to design web application there
is considerably better and more complete
documentation for vue.js it facilitates
and the straightforward creation of
template based apps
HTML JavaScript and CSS are used
individually by vue.js
vue.js used a templates based approach
vue.js has considerable easier
integration syntax and adaption now
let's see the component approach between
react.js and vue.js
first react claims that everything is
straightforward you can use the same
skills to create native IOS and Android
apps using react native here view stuff
the alibaba's groups Wix project a
cross-platform UI framework has formal
support from view with Vex you can
simultaneously design components for IOS
and Android as well as browser using the
same ux syntax Vex is still in the
active development stage and is not as
mature or experience tested as react
native a native script plugins for
creating genuinely native apps with
vue.js is another variation of native
script slash view HTML template are used
for component design in vue.js now let's
discuss more about this
similar to react vue.js suggests
combining the logic and user interface
into one file the view JS component code
is contained in a particular HTML
template the component code is clearly
visible thanks to the template it makes
it easier for programmers to monitor the
method look at the properties and check
for the router render function
the Syntax for view JS is particular
double packets are used as a placeholder
for the data the directives in view JS
are HTML attributes and they can begin
with the prefix view slash the system
for the framework considers of objects
classes and behavior types
it is consistent with programmers
knowledge of object oriented programming
let's see react uses jxx and simple file
component structure
components render the data on web
browser then include the UI part which
is shown to the user HTML and the logic
JavaScript the logic describes functions
and method to communicate the data in
the browser react uses JavaScript syntax
extension jsx a syntax language that
helps write functions correspondence
lead to Native method for browser
Safari Chrome and Firefox are based on
JavaScript engines that can directly
talk with the logic functions written in
the react since JavaScript code is
enriched with HTML tags it can't be
recognized by the web browser so react
is converting the programming code to
the pure JavaScript using Bible
transpilter
jsx allows to return HTML in JavaScript
also JavaScript variables can be
assigned to HTML tags let's move on to
the next part which is react versus view
flexibility reacts core only offers
minimal capabilities the practical
application of this library in sicity
it's the explanation of its capabilities
this provides the developer with a lot
of options when picking out a new tool
additional libraries are typically used
to resolve creation of mobile
application server rendering and
application State Management in contrast
to react view offers a developer a wider
range of standard tools this enables you
to use third-party libraries to address
the same issue that the react ecosystem
often addresses
now
let's move on to the differences between
react and the vue.js
react is a JavaScript library that is
created and using the jsx approach while
view is a model view view model
JavaScript framework which is also known
as mbvm
this takes a template based approach
react was available for the public on
May 2013 and view was and available in
February 2014.
we can create both interactive web
applications and mobile application
using react
while we can create web apps using view
react application is in normal speed but
on the other hand view is faster and
smoother react was created by Facebook
and view was created by laravel and
Alibaba
State Management library of react is
called mobex and State Management
library of view is called view X now
let's move on to the popular websites
created by vue.js
first one is behance the second one is
gitlab the third one is Trivago and the
fourth one is nine gag now let's move on
to see the popular websites using react
Facebook Instagram Netflix pin interest
and Twitter
now let's see which businesses might
need to choose react over review early
stages startups that needed fast feature
development and validate campaigns on
the market companies that are looking to
Outsource their Department it is much
easier to find a react developer
compared to the one with vue.js
expertise
product based companies will also
require
cross-platforming app development react
native based on react technologies that
it will be a good fit now let's see
which businesses might need to choose
view over react
companies that approach the market of
web-based products the companies that
are looking to implement a single flow
on in their development process
companies with no previous experience of
using Frameworks in either build process
or those looking to leverage their
professionalities with JavaScript so
with this we have reached the end of
this video If you find this video
informative please like and comment and
subscribe to our YouTube channel thank
you
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here